a convoy of 200 Vehicles carrying
Americans protesting against migrants
entering the country drove to the Border
they call themselves God's Army we are
definitely the army of God I wear my
cross every day Minnesota Mike says Get
your butt down to the Border what do you
what's your message when you get down
there shut the border keep it
closed initially self-described by some
part participants as a Christian militia
the Convoy in reality Ended as a rally a
half kilometer from the border near
Eagle Pass Texas the epicenter of
Migrant arrivals police searched for
weapons but while the rhetoric was
charged with anger and some
misinformation the event itself was
peaceful it's to tearing apart all of
our major cities um Texas especially I
mean this is the front door and um
they're everywhere the US recorded more
than 300 thousand unauthorized border
crossings in December a record high most
people are fleeing violence and poverty
in Latin America many bringing their
children a few Pro migrant Advocates
arrived to counter the Convoy we see
these border towns as our modern-day
Ellis Islands these are the places where
future generations of Americans will
tell their story about how their
families came into the country this
rally is as much about border policy as
it is about Poli ICS most people here
are supporters of Donald Trump and they
hope that immigration the issue that
elevated him to the White House in 2016
will help Trump win again so this isn't
a political movement it is Christ
Calvary but uh most everybody here
supports Donald Trump and we don't see
any other way to make our country right
the protesters blame President Joe Biden
for the Border problem Biden says he's
done all he can using executive powers
and that Congress must now Act Heidi Joe
Castro Al jazer Kato
Texas make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer